[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يوصف بمن دل الماليزي فعوامل
التشابه بين تجربتين كثيره وكما قاد
الزعيم الجنوب افريقي بلاده بعد سنوات من
السجن والمعاناه صعد انور ابراهيم هو
الاخر الى سده رئاسه الوزراء في بلده
ماليزيا بعد سجن تكرر اكثر من مره عرف عن
ابراهيم نشاطه السياسي المبكر وبرز اثناء
دراسته في الجامعه الملاويه كطالب يحمل
روحا ثوريه فقاده تظاهرات ضد الفساد واخرى
مدافعه عن الفلاحين الفقراء في ماليزيا
وبسببها كانت تجربه السجن الاولى منتصف
السبعينات حيث استمرت لنحو عامين وعلى ما
يبدو فان النشاط المبكر رسم الطريقه امام
ابراهيم بجله ولم تثني تجربه السجن عزم
السياسي الشعب او تتبع طموحه فاسس عقب
تخرجه حركه الشباب المسلم وانتقد بشده
ائتلاف الجبهه الوطنيه الحاكم لتترسخ سوره
القيادي الساعي للاصلاح والتغيير لا فتى
نشاطه اهتمام رئيس الوزراء الماليزي حينئذ
مهاتير محمد وبعين السياسيه الخبير دعاه
مطلع الثمانينات من القرن الماضي للالتحاق
بحزب المنظمه الملاوميه القوميه المتحده
الذي كان ابراهيم دائما انتقاد لها وكان
مفاجئا اللب الاخير الدعوه لكن وكما عبد
للالتحاق بحزب امنه الطريقه امام انور
ابراهيم لصعود سريع وحمل حقائب وزاريه عده
وجعله على مرمى حجر خلافه مهاتير محمد
فانه اودعه من جديد غياهب السجون وادخله
لاحقا في رحله معاناه استمرت لربع قرن
ومعها تبدلت علاقته بمهاتير من الوئام الى
الخصومه قبل ان يعود الرجلان الى التحالف
مجددا عام 2016 مشاهدينا الكرام رئيس
الوزراء الماليزي انور ابراهيم في حلقه
ثانيه مع الرجل فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
تقلد منصب رئيس الوزراء في ماليزيا منذ
نوفمبر عام 2022 ولد عام
1947 ويعد من رواد التيار الاسلامي
الاصلاحي في ماليزيا اسس وتراسل الاتحاد
الماليزي للشباب المسلمين بين عامي 71 و
1982 اعجب مهاتير محمد بنشاطه فدعاه
للالتحاق بحزب امنو عام 82 ارتقى سريعا
داخل الحزب واصبح احد ابرز شخصياته شغل
وزارات عده بين عامي 83
و98 اهمها الماليه والزراعه والتربيه عرض
رؤيته لنهضه ماليزيا في كتاب النهضه
الاسيويه عام
1996 في العام التالي توترت علاقته بمهاتر
محمد نتيجه الازمه الاقتصاديه الاسيويه
طرح حلا لتراجع الاقتصاد الماليزي استنادا
الى اسس ليبراليه جذب قلوبه دعم مجتمع
الاعمال الغربي والدوائر السياسيه
الامريكيه واتهم بالفساد وصدر ضده حكم
بالسجن بعد ادانته عام
1998 جرت تبرئه واطلق سراحه في عام 2004
بعد استقاله مهاتير محمد عاد الى السياسه
من باب التحالف مع المعارضه وانتخب نائبا
بالبرلمان الماليزي عام 2008 حيث طالب
باجراء اصلاحات تزعم المعارضه في البرلمان
خلال الفتره بين عامين 2008 و2015
ودافع عن حريه الصحافه والاقتصاد الحر
وطالب بمكافحه الفساد حكم عليه بالسجن
مجددا عام 2015 بعد نقض الحكم السابق
بتبرئته تصالح مع مهاتر محمد وعاد للتحالف
معه وفاز بالاغلبيه عام 2018
انشق مع بعض الشخصيات عمهاتير في عام 2020
وكلف بتشكيل الحكومه بعد تصدر تحالف الامل
الذي يتزعمه الانتخابات في عام 2022
السيده نور ابراهيم اسمح لي ان اركز في
هذا الجزء على مسيرتك الشخصيه انور
ابراهيم القائد الاستثنائي المسلم
المتفتح الحديث المؤمن بالحداثه والمؤسس
بشكل ممتاز والذي ارتبط اسمه بمشوار
ماليزيا ونهضتها ونجاحها
ركزنا في الجزئاب على القضايا السياسيه
بشكل اكبر وعلى دورك ومهمتك كرئيس وزراء
كيف استطعت ان تكون الامرين انت اسست
منظمه الشباب المسلم في بداياتك بعد تخرجك
من الجامعه في نهايه الستينات
وايضا انت
مطلع على الحداثه على العلم انت منغمس في
الحداثه يعني في العالم الحديث ولا تنظر
له بعده او بقطيعه كيف استطعت الموازنه
بين ان تكون مسلما ملتزما
وان تكون منفتحا بهذه الدرجه الكبيره ايضا
علي
يا علي لقد كنت لطيفا للغايه انا لاعب
بسيط في هذا الامر استفيد كثيرا مما اتعلم
ومما اراه من امثله للكثير من الاشخاص
مسلمين وحتى غير مسلمين لقد ذكرت مانديلا
في الجزء السابق من مقابلتك اعتقد انني
اريد ان اكون ماليزيا جيدا ثقافيا كما
افهم ماليزيا جيدا لكنني مسلم ملتزم وافهم
الاسلام على انه طريقه حياه ودين معا كما
تعلمون ويتضمن افكارا عن العداله
والانسانيه والرحمه واقول انه لا يوجد
اسلام بدون روح الاصلاح ولا يوجد اسلام
بدون رحمه لكن في بعض الاحيان حتى بين
المسلمين نميل الى ان نكون غير متسامحين
وممتلئين بالكراهيه اذا تحدثوا في
الكونجرس والبرلمان وحتى المسلمين لم يكن
سوى كراهيه واحتقار وتمييز لا يوجد حب
وعاطف ه فهمي للاسلام هو التسامح والرحمه
والعداله بالطبع العدل والاحسان وهذا
بالنسبه لي الاساسيات بالطبع نصلي بشكل
مختلف عن الديانات الاخرى نظام معتقدات
مختلف
لكن هناك موقف لذلك اعتقد انني لست كما
تعلم فريدا من نوعي لان هناك الكثير من
الناس قدموا افكار رائعه حول هذا الموضوع
ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك توافق عندما اقول
ذلك فلماذا اتخذ موقفا ضد الصينيين في
الصين او الهنود او الغرب او امريكا انا
اختلف معهم في بعض القضايا لكن دعونا نعمل
معا اعني انه في رايي هذا رصيد كبير
ما الذي دفعك الاتجاه الاسلامي في بدايه
حياتك يا سيدي انور ابراهيم انت مسلم من
الطبيعه ان تكون لديك يعني نظره اسلاميه
او رؤيه او خلفيه اسلاميه لكن انت انت
اسلامي اكثر اسست منظمه الشباب من اثر بك
بمن تاثرت لماذا اتجهت هذا الاتجاه
تم اسلامي
يا علي انت تستخدم مصطلح اصول اسلامي كما
تعلم هذا يعطي تصورات مختلفه نعم انا مسلم
ملتزم اجل كنت في حركات الشباب اقصد
ولماذا اخترت هذه المنظمه الاسلاميه لانني
ادرك انها قضيه هويه لانه لا يوجد احترام
للدين لا يوجد احترام للاسلام وكان
الاسلام يختصر على من هم في القران كما
تعلم للشيخ المحافظ وعندما تتحدث عن
العداله والرحمه والتنميه الاقتصاديه فليس
لهم علاقه بالاسلام وانت تتعلم الاسلام
مما يقترحه اسياد الاستعمار وقلت هذا ليس
الاسلام بطريقه التي افهمها لذلك بدات
القراءه وبدات افهم وبدات في نشره بين
المسلمين واقول انظروا الاسلام اسلوب حياه
انه يتعلق بالعداله منه يتعلق بالتسامح في
الوقت نفسه عندما كنت اقود حركه الشباب
المسلم كنت اقود حركه الشباب الماليزيه مع
الهندوس والبوذيين والمسيحيين لم يتم
الحديث عنها لكنها حقيقه تعني لي ان
الحديث عن دوله موحده لا يعني انك تتنازل
او تتجاهل نظام
معتقداتكريم
انت لست كذلك ولست بحاجه الى ان تكون
متطرفا او علمانيا لتكون تقدنيا انا افهم
الاقتصاد بطريقتي اريد ان تتقدم الدوله
وافهم النظام المالي وحدوده لكن عليك ان
تحافظ على الهويه كان هذا وقتا فيه الكثير
من الجهل بالدين والاسلام على وجه الخصوص
هناك الكثير من التحيز على الرغم من ان
مصطلح الاسلام فوبيا لم يكن شائعا في ذلك
الوقت
ولكن بعد ذلك مصطلح ان الاسلام رجعي
والاسلام ضد التنميه وهذا الاسلام كما
تعلمون دفعني الى محاربه النظام الفكري
الاستعماري الذي ورثناه هذا الفهم للاسلام
من وجهه نظر الاستعمار البريطاني هذا هو
سبب انشاء حركه الشباب الاسلامي وتعزيز
هذا الفهم للاسلام الاسلام المتطرف من
ناحيه الاسلام السياسي الحزبي ضيق الافق
هو بالنسبه لي الذي يمكن ان يشكل خطرا
عندما يبداون في التمييز ضد الاخرين او
ادانتهم من من المفكرين ترك مفكرين
الاسلاميين ترك اثره على انور ابراهيم
بشكل كبير سواء في ماليزيا وفي العالم
العربي وفي العالم الاسلامي بشكل عام
مسلمه
قران
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم بالطبع كمسلم
عليك ان تدرس القران وسنه النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وتتبع الصحابه في سيره عمر بن عبد العزيز
توصلنا الى شيء ما شخص مثال غير عادي
بامتياز من حيث الحكم والتواضع كما تعلمون
بين العلماء المعاصرين نرى محمد اقبال
الباكستاني حتى من نواحي كثيره في كتاب
عبد الرحمن الكواكبي الذي قراته بشكل عميق
وحتى الاشخاص الاكثر اثاره الجدل عندما
اقول هذا فانا متاكد من اثاره بعض الجدل
لانني اريد ان اذكر حسن البنا لكن
بالتاكيد ليس الاتجاه السائده فيما يتعلق
بالعنف او الطائفيه انا اتحدث عن افكار
حول التسامح وفهم الاسلام حامد الله
الباكستاني او حتى الحركه الاندونيسيه
وبعد ذلك كان هناك الكثير مثل مالك بن نبي
في الجزائر الذي يعتقد انه مفكر رائع
وجدير بالثناء واصيل نحن نتحدث عن افكار
السكان الاصليين حول توجيه الافكار هذا
ليس المنتدى لكن يا علي انت تستفزني
للتفكير بصوت عال لكن في بعض الاحيان لا
يعني ان الناس لا تريد اتباع النبي لا
تتبعه بشكل كلي بنسبه مئه في المئه هذه
بعض الافكار غالبا ذات الصله
وبعضها بالطبع يجب ان نفكر فيه مليا
وبالمثل اقبال نشا اقبال في الهند مع
اعتدام الصراع بين المسلمين والهندوس
لكنني اتحدث عن فكرته عن التجديد واعاده
بناء الفكر الاسلامي
لذلك عندما ذكرت حسن البنا على الفور
لاكون كما تعلمون اصبح الامر مثير للجدل
للغايه خاصه في العالم العربي
وواجهت الكثير من المشاكل بسبب ذلك لانني
اميل الى الصراحه
اقول نعم استفيد من بعض افكاره لكنني لا
لست جزءا من الحركه لم يكن الاخوان حضورا
في ماليزيا في تلك الفتره الاخوان
المسلمين في نهايه الستينات السبعينات
كتيار سياسي اما السيده اخوان
يجب ان اقول ان للاخوان بعض التاثير لكن
هناك بعض الجماعات الصغيره التي تتبعهم
نحن لا نتبعهم لقد اتخذنا وجهه نظر اكثر
انفتاحا لاننا قريبون جدا من الاسلام
الاندونيسي وهو كما تعلمون جزء لا يتجزا
من هذه الثقافه واللغه لذلك اعتقد ان هذا
الاتجاه محدود وليس ذا اهميه ربما من
الجيد ان لم تصل تاثيرات الاسلاميين العرب
لانه المشاكل كثيره لم تصل الى ماليزيا
ولا حتى الاندونيسيا
منذ البدايه كنت غاضبا سيدا وابراهيم قلت
مظاهرات ضد الفساد في المرحله الجامعيه
بعد بعد الجامعه يعني كنت مشتبكا مع
المجال السياسي بشكل رئيسي ما الذي كان
يحركك او
كنت شابا ومثاليا جدا مع هؤلاء الفاسدين
وفي محاربه الفساد تم توقيفي لاول مره
لمده ثلاثه ايام لانني كنت اتساءل لماذا
في ذلك الوقت كان هناك الكثير من الفضائع
في جنوب تايلاند بين المسلمين ثم بعد ذلك
تم اعتقال لمده عامين دون محاكمه بسبب
انتقاد لانتشار الفقر في مقاطعه كلح في
الشمال والناس الذين يكافحون من اجل العيش
واقول انها ستكون مستقله لذلك قوموا بهذه
التظاهرات اول سجن كان سنتين
بدا طريق السجن مبكرا يعني
[ضحك]
نعم اعرف حقا هذا منحني فرصه للتعلم ماذا
تفعل في السجن انت تقرا عندما تحفظ القران
تقرا كما تعلم مجموعه الاحاديث النبويه
باكملها وتقرا كل النصوص الاقتصاد السياسه
مقارنه الاديان لذلك في الواقع ليس الامر
بهذا السوء لانه يمكنك استغلال جزء كبير
من وقتك
دائما السجل لم يكن سيئا ولا في بعض
الاحيان كان سيئا
[موسيقى]
وبريزن
كما قال ليس فراشا من الورود او الاشياء
لقد اصبحت نحيل جدا كان الطعام غير مناسب
لاحقا عندما كنت اكبر سنا كنت في الحبس
الانفرادي وكانت تفكير في حياتك امرا صعبا
والدك يتقدمان في السن ثم الاطفال مات
والدي عندما كنت في السين مات اخي اثنان
من اخوتي واخت واحده جميعهم ماتوا عندما
كنت في السجن وكان الامر صعبا بالطبع
عندما تركتك والدتك وانت في الحبس
الانفرادي لذا فالامر ليس بهذه السهوله
لكن ما اقوله هو انني استغل وقتي للتامل
وادعو الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يمنحني القوه
وان اتعلم قدر الامكان عن كل ما هو متاح
يبدو تم الانتباه لك سيد انور ابراهيم
مبكرا انك يعني
اسم سيبرز كثيرا فتم استقطابك من امنه من
مهاتير محمد في بدايه الثمانينات
لكنك تركت على طول يعني كان هذا يحسب ضدك
انه تركت انت يا جماعه الاسلاميه وانتقلت
الى حزب امنه مباشره كانت مفاجاه
لقد كانت مفاجاه للعديد من اصدقائي بعضهم
كان دائما وبعضهم كان محايدا والبعض الاخر
كان غاضبا جدا استطيع ان افهم لكن في
الوقت الحاضر جاء صوت الاصلاح باجنده
واضحه لتنظيف الحكومه والانعاش الاقتصاد
لذلك
اعتقدت ان الوقت قد حان فقد كنت ابلغ
حوالي 30 او 31
فقلت حسنا لم اعد من الشباب اطلاقا لذلك
دعني اعمل وقد منحني مساحه للعمل
ولكن بعد ذلك عندما بدات تصبح اكثر قوه
واعبر عن بعض اراء
في ذلك تحديا والباقي للتاريخ
[موسيقى]
ينظر الى العلاقه بين مهاتير محمد وانور
ابراهيم على انها علاقه المعلم بالتلميذ
فقد رسخ ابراهيم مكانته السياسيه عبر
البوابه الواسعه لحزب المنظمه الملاويه
القوميه المتحده امنه بدعوه من مهاتير اما
مهاتير فيقر من جهتي بامكانات ابراهيم
الفائقه ويقول في مذكراته انه اعجب بذكاء
السياسي الشاب حين التحق بحزب امنه
وبالطريقه التي خرج بها من الاتحاد
الاسلامي ومعسكره دون قطع روابطه به الى
جانب تمكنه من اقناع احزاب المعارضه بانه
يتفق معها جميعا
عينه مهاتير لمنصب مساعد وزير فجاءه
ابراهيم معبرا عن خيبه امله لانه لم
يختاره وزيره وكان الرد بانه لا احد قفز
من ناقد للحكومه الى عضو كامل فيها خلال
هذا الوقت القصير
وكتفا بكتف مضى الرجلان في طريق النهضه
بماليزيا البلد الذي كانت مؤشرته السابقه
تنبئ بوقوعه في ذيل الترتيب الدولي بما
يعانيه ان اذن من فقر ومرض وتخلف يصيب
مهاتير في وصف قدرات ابراهيم فيقول انه
كان قادرا على ادهاش العامه ونيل اعجاب
الصحفيين الامريكيين والغربيين بافكاره
التي تبدو ليبراليه ونجاحه في الترتيب
زياره سنويه لاعضاء في مجلسي النواب
والشيوخ الامريكيين الى ماليزيا
كان طموح ابراهيم ان يشغل موقع مساعد رئيس
الحزب فاتقى للتقضي بتعيين شاغل هذا
المنصب مساعدا لرئيس الحكومه ما يعني انه
سيصبح الرجل الثاني في البلاد وبحسب
مهاتير في مذكراته فان ابراهيم لم يلبث عن
اتجه ببصره الى منصب رئيس الحكومه فانطلق
يهاجم الفساد في السلطه ويلمح الى فساد
رئيس الحكومه نفسه وقام بابلاغ الصحافه
بقضايا فساد قال ان رئيس الحكومه هو بطلها
ثم جاء العام 97 حاملا معه الشقاق بين
الرجلين بسبب الخلاف بشان اجراءات التعافي
من الازمه الماليه الاسيويه لتتصاعد
الاحداث بعد ذلك ويواجه ابراهيم تهما
ماليه واخلاقيه وفي حين يحلل البعض النظر
الى ابراهيم على انه كان متطلعا للسلطه
على الدوام يقول اخرون ان الانتقام منه
شكل احدى البقع السوداء القليله التي لطخ
الثوب مهات ير الناصع
اهم علاقه هي علاقتك امام هاتير تحالفا
معارضه اختلافا
كيف تصف الرجل
[موسيقى]
اوكلوز
كنت قريبا جدا منه بالطبع كنت نائبه
وعملت بجد ودعمتهم لكن الان بالطبع لا
يوجد هناك اي اتصال اعرف حتى على سبيل
المثال انه هاجمني باستمرار مرات لا تحصى
ولكنني نادر ما ارد اعتقد كما تعلم بان
اتركه وشانه اعتقد ان اخر مره طلب مني في
احدى المقابلات الاعلاميه مع الناس
التعليق على هذه النقطه قلت فقط اتركه
وشانه واعتقد انه في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه امتنع عن اي انتقاده امل ان يستمر
هذا لانه حتى لو فعل ذلك لا اعتقد انه
يتوجب علي ان ارد اريد المضي قدما لدي
مسؤوليه تجاه بلدي وتجاه شعبي وهم يستحقون
افضل لماذا فعل مهاتير ما فعله معك برايك
حسنا يجب ان تساله ذلك يا علي فاجاني ذلك
ايضا لانه مهما كانت الاختلافات بيننا لم
اكن ارغب في تحديه في ذلك الوقت لكن لديه
مجموعه من المستشارين كما تعلمون قالوا
غير ذلك وكانوا يشعرون بالتهديد اذا تقلدت
منصبا عاليا فان كل هذا الفساد وعمليات
الاثراء او ما تم اخفاؤه في قوي مظلم
وتبديد الاموال سينكشف اعتقد ان هذه هي
المشكله الاساسيه ثم اقنعوه بذلك ولان
انور لديه بعض الدعم عليهم ان يعاقبوه
بطريقه سيئه لانهم يفعلون ذلك في الوضع
الطبيعي كما تعلمون قد لا يكون ذلك جيدا
بالنسبه له هذا ما حدث لقد اصبح قاسي جدا
جدا وبارد المشاعر لدرجه انني تعرضت
للاعتداء حتى الموت
اعني لاي سبب لم اقاتل جسديا ضد اي شخص لم
اكون عقليه متطرفه او تسببت كما تعلمون في
حرب اهليه لكن الحياه يجب ان تستمر كما
تعلم يجب ان اقول هذا يا علي لا اريد ان
اعطي انطباعا بان كل ما ستعرفه عني انني
رجل قوي روحانيا لا لا انا بالطبع اديت
الواجبات الدينيه لكنني ايضا غنيت قليلا
في السجن لذلك هذا هو التوازن
حين كنا شبابا سيد انور
كنا نحب مهاتير محمد
لا نحبه لشخصه ولكنه نحبه لانه صاحب تجربه
نهضويه في ماليزيا وكنا نعتقد ان اي شخص
يختلف مع مهاتره وشخصيه
فكنا ايضا تسرب الى بعضنا عدم محبه انور
ابراهيم بسبب الخلاف مع مهاتير لكن مع
المسيره السياسيه وما اتضح لاحقا
تكشفت امور لم تكن يعني لم تكن مثل تلك
الصوره الذهن الصوره الورديه التي كانت
لدينا عن السياسيين في ماليزيا يعني
الخصومه وصلت الى اتهامك بشكل فج باتهامات
لم تكن يعني او او علاقه لم تثبت يعني
كانت اتهمت مسيسه بشكل كبير جدا لماذا وصل
الصراع بينك وبين مهاتير الى هذه الدرجه
التي اودت بك الى السجن عده مرات هل هي
الغيره بمعنى الخشيه من انور ابراهيم
البديل
لمهاتير محمد
ما كان هو هو الزمره مؤيدين الاشخاص
الاساسيون قلقين بالفعل منه انني كنت
قريبا جدا من تولي منصب رئيس الوزراء
ويعتقدون انه لا يمكن الوثوق به لانني
ادعو الى الاصلاح اذا قرات مثلا كتابي عصر
النهضه الاسيويه رغم انني لم اكن انتقد مع
التير محمد عندما اتحدث عن القضاء وانه
يجب ان يكون القضاء مستقلا ويجب تخليص
البلاد من الفساد اعني هذه افكاري وهم
يشعرون انه اذا تم تكليفه بان اصبح رئيسا
للوزراء فسيكون ذلك خطرا عليهم هذا ليس
صحيحا بالضروره لكنني بالطبع اريد ان انقذ
البلد
[موسيقى]
الان من المثير للاهتمام ما قلته يا علي
لانه بعد اطلاق سراحي واجراء الجراحه في
ميونخ احضرني الملك عبد الله ملك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى السعوديه لاداء
العمره والاقامه كما تعلم للتعافي في مكه
المكرمه والمدينه
والتقيت بالطبع بالعديد من الاصدقاء
السعوديين يقول معظمهم الشيء نفسه كما
فعلت يتساءلون لماذا بسبب ماذا وهذا صحيح
مهما كانت اخطائه فقد كان له دور فعال في
تقدم هذا البلد في الصناعه وتطور الحديث
وكنت نائبه كنت وزير ماليته لذلك اعتقد
اننا ندين بالفضل لذلك بالمناسبه هناك
تجاوزات لانه ادى ايضا الى تدمير مؤسسات
الحكم والخدمه المدنيه والقضاء كما تعلمون
هل كانت ثمه الجوازات بالمحيط الضيق
لمهاتير محمد اسرته اقاربه
اعتقد ان دوائره الداخليه وعائلته كما
تعلمون شركاء مقربون لكن هذا مؤسف اعتقد
انه عند حكم على الناس يجب علي النظر الى
الجانب الايجابي القوي والجانب السلبي
ايضا ولكن الان في الوقت الحالي يجب ان
تستمر الحياه اصبح ماتير جزء من الماضي
التاريخ سيكون رحيما به وفي هذه الحقبه
فقد لعب دورا محوريا في دفع البلاد الى
اعلى السلم لكنني اعتقد اننا سنكون اقل
لطفا عندما يتعلق الامر بقضايا الحكم
والظلم هل انتهى السياسيين تماما برايك
دكتور محمد
او ربما يفاجئ الجميع
انا قابلته كان عمره 92 اسس حزب معارض عاد
لرئاسه الوزراء في السن الاربعه وتسعين
والله اعلم هل ستزور
ليس الان دحو يهدا ويستقر وليس هناك اي
غضب او ياس عندما يكون مستقرا انا لا
امانع يعني لقد عملت معه تذكر انه يجب ان
لا ننسى اننا في عام 2018 حاولنا العمل
معهم وقع اتفاقا يتنازل فيه عن السلطه لي
لم اقم بذلك ولكنني دعمته
ذهبت لرؤيته لتقديم دعمي لكنني اعتقد الان
انه يجب ان نجعل الامور تستقر لابد لي من
الاستقرار لكن دحور ربما يهدا قليلا ثم
انه لا اعتقد انه يجب ان يكون لدينا هذا
العداء الشخصي او السياسه او شيء ما يسبب
الكثير من العداء بين الافراد لا يجب ذلك
قد تكون لدينا اختلافات لكن لنحافظ على
كياستنا حسنا لست بحاجه الى الاعتداء على
الناس والسي بهم في السجن
طبيبه العيون التي تخلت عن مهنتها وابتعدت
عن الرقه المستشفيات لتدخل معترك السياسه
ادركت عزيزه اسماعيل مبكرا ان ارتباطها
برجل مثل انور ابراهيم سيضعها تحت الاضواء
الكاشفه وكان اعتقال زوجها في سبتمبر عام
98 محطه مفصليه في حياه المراه التي دخلت
مضطره لعالم السياسه والقياده من اوسع
ابوابه
الغياب القسري للزوج دفع بالزوجه الى تولي
تسير شؤون حزب العداله الوطنيه الذي تاسس
عام 99 وحدت صفوف المعارضه ووضعت على سلم
اولوياتها الافراج عن انور الذي اصبحت
قضيته احدى اسخن القضايا السياسيه في
التاريخ المعاصر للدوله الاسيويه
بين عامي 99 و2008 انتخبت طبيبه الامس
نائبه في البرلمان عن نفس الدائره التي
كان يمثلها زوجها في السابق واستمرت في
لعب دور مؤثر وفعال في صفوف المعارضه ثم
استقلت في شهر يوليو عام 2008 من البرلمان
لفتح المجال امام عوده زوجها الذي فاز في
الانتخابات الفرعيه في شهر اغسطس من العام
نفسه لكن ما لبثت ان عادت مره اخرى في
مارس من العام 2014
لتتصدر واجهه الاحداث السياسيه مجددا وذلك
بعد ايداع زوجها السجن الثانيه خاضت
الانتخابات النيابيه التكميليه وانتخبت
مره اخرى نائبه في البرلمان وفي شهر مايو
عام 2015 عينت زعيمه للمعارضه في البرلمان
الماليزي وكانت المره الاولى التي تتولى
فيها زعامه الكتله المعارضه في مايو عام
2018 خاضت عزيزه اسماعيل
اخيرا نزال سياسي لها ثم دخلت في تحالف
سياسي مع مهاتير محمد تحالف فاز في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي اطاحت بحكومه
الخصم العنيد نجيب عبد الرزاق في تحول
الدراماتيكي ما هذا لوصول انور ابراهيم
الى سده رئاسه الحكومه في ماليزيا
تقول في الانستغرام في تعريفك انا زوج
فخور
والسيده عزيزه يعني وقفت الى جانبك
نسميها نحن العرب وقفه الرجال
فكيف تنظر لزوجتك وللادوار السياسيه
والادوار الشخصيه التي لعبتها معك في
فترات غيابك في السجن
ويس هارون
لقد تم الاستخفاف بدورها وهو امر خاطئ
انت تعرف انني ما انا عليه الان
خصوصا في فتره الشده والضيق
كانت متماسكه وواضحه وتؤمن بالقضيه ثم
قامت بتربيه اطفال السته في فتره غيابي
لسته اعوام ثم ما يقرب من عشر سنوات
وايضا بعد 9 سنوات
من اول عامين بعد زواجي خاضت الرمارسه
وجالت في جميع انحاء البلاد على الرغم من
انها ليست سياسيه فهي طبيبه عيون لكنها
مضت قدما وانا افتخر بها ليس لانها زوجتي
لكن بصراحه كانت رائعه انا محظوظ جدا من
اع الاشياء التي حققتها في حياتي ان
اتزوجها وان تكون فريقي
هل اكتسبت يعني طبيعه سياسيه
بعملها السياسي خاصه العضويه البرلمان
اكثر من مره وادارت الحزب في غيابك اثناء
وجودك في السجن هل اصبحت السياسيه ام انها
فقط
تمارس هذا الدور السياسي نيابه عنك لحين
عودتك
انه شيء
عزيزه امين لا ارى انها لا تزال عزيزه على
سبيل المثال
اذا وجدتني جافا في حديثي فسوف تتراجع
قليلا وتقول ابقى هذا انت تعلم انها لا
تختار ان تهاجم نادرا ما كانت تتحدث في
البرلمان
كانت في وقت من الاوقات زعيمه المعارضه
ونادر جدا عندما رات احد الوزراء كان
احدهم فظا جدا وعدائيا ثم وقفت وواجهت لكن
على خلاف ذلك فهي هادئه جدا اكثر هدوءا
ورويه مني واعتقد انها دائما ما تستخدم
ذلك الاتزان والهدوء وتطلب مني ان لا اجيب
من فعال وهي دائما تظهر الجانب الاكثر
ليونه لتهدئه الامور ابنتك ايضا اليوم
عينتها مستشاره
هذا محل انتقاد لك
حسنا انا اقبل النقد اردت ان تكون احدهم
ولكن بالطبع هناك العديد من المستشارين
وهي واحده منهم لكنني اعتقدت كما تعلمت
انها قريبه مني وليس لها راتب وعلى عكس
المستشارين الاخرين فهي لا تحصل على راتب
فقط ولكنها لا تمنح اتفاقات للحصول على
عقود مع الاصدقاء لقد وثقت بشخص مثلها
لكنني اعتقد بعد الانتقاد ان كل الاتباع
يشككون في نفاق اولئك الذين عينوا اولادهم
لذلك كما قلت لك عندما تكون في السلطه
كوزير للماليه او كرئيس الوزراء وتمنح
مئات الملايين من الدولارات من العقود
لابنك ثم تاتي وتحدثني عن المحسوبيه لكن
على اي حال هذا انتقاد لقد قبلت استقالتها
وهي الان تعمل فقط مع الامانه العامه
تساعد مستشاري وزاره الماليه التي يراسها
رئيس تنفيذي بارز جدا في بتروناس
من يعجبك من القاده المسلمين او يعني تشعر
انك قريب او او تقدر ما يقوم به من العمل
كما تعلم حاول القاده في مختلف مجالاتهم
القيام باشياء لتغيير المجتمع لقد ذكرت
امير قطر بسبب نجاحه في التعامل مع امر
كان كثيرون يتحكمون عليه بلد صغير اجل غني
وتتمكن من اداره ذلك بنجاح وبالطبع حولت
اندونيسيا نفسها بعده طرق من نظام مستبد
الى مجتمع اكثر الديمقراطيه
تركي سيميلالي طيب
ايضا برزت كصوت مهم للعالم الاسلامي في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يمكنك ان ترى
محاولات الشروع في بعض الاصلاحات والتحديد
لذا فقد راينا دبي وبعض المدن بالطبع
ذكرنا هذا وما نتعلمه من قوه ولكن في
ماليزيا ساقوم بفعل بعض الاشياء بشكل
مماثل وبعض الاشياء بطريقه مختلفه لذلك
نتعلم ما نعتقد انه نقاط قوتنا ولكنه لا
يمنعنا من رؤيه بعض العيوب في النظام او
في محاوله الاصلاح او التغيير معتبره نقاط
ضعف لا ينبغي تكرارها في ماليزيا
شعرنا ماليزيا كانت طرف يعني في تحالفات
اسلاميه كانت ثمه التحالف في الفتره
الماضيه او تقارب ما بين او محاوله لبناء
تقارب بين تركيا ماليزيا وباكستان هل
سياستكم ان تكون جزءا من محور اسلامي
لا اعتقد انه يجب علينا تجزئه الامر بهذا
الشكل تركيا بلد مهم لقد كنت قريبا جدا من
قطر وباكستان قريبه جدا من نافئ اسيا
لطالما كانت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حليفا مهما للغايه في معظم ارتباطاتنا
الثنائيه
مشروم
الامارات الان دوله مهمه ايضا اعتقد اننا
اتخذنا هذا الموقف اعتقد ان سياستنا هي
التاكد من اننا نعزز هذا النوع من
العلاقات ونحد من التوترات الممكنه لانه
بالنسبه لماليزيا فان مصلحتها هي القيام
بذلك ولا سيما لعب دور مهم في العالم
الاسلامي مع شركائنا
على ذكر المسلمين والعرب وذكرت الدول
العربيه ومن ضمنها قطر في الفتره الماضيه
عن تنظيم كاس العالم شعرنا بهذه الحاله
المتوتره في الغرب تجاه اي اي نجاحات تحدث
في العالم العربي او العالم الاسلامي بشكل
عام تحديدا اتجاه كاس العالم قضيه الخوف
من الاسلام انت يعني قائد اسلامي وكذلك
ايضا يعني عملتها في الغرب ودرست هناك
وتعرف جيدا تفاصيل هذه الثقافه الغربيه
كيف تنظر لي هذا التوجس الغربي من اي نجاح
يحدث في العالم العربي او في العالم
الاسلامي هذه الحاله حاله المتناميه
المضاده لكل ما يجري في في العالم
الاسلامي
اترى ان المشكله تتعلق بالاسلام فوبيا لقد
تحدثت مع المستشار الالماني عندما كان هنا
قلت له علينا جميعا العمل ولا سيما مع
الغرب لمحاوله الحد من هذا العداء والتحيز
نظمت قطر بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم
ببراعه لن يشكك احد بذلك وفي الحقيقه
فاجئه الكثيرين
انا لست خبيرا في هذا حتى انني سالت الملك
الذي كان منخرطا للغايه كرئيس الاتحاد كره
القدم لعقود في اسيا والمجتمع الدولي وقال
انه يرى ايضا ان تنظيم كان رائعا بالنسبه
لبعض وسائل الاعلام الغربيه بسبب الاسلام
فوبيا لا يمكنهم ان يفهموا كيف يمكن
العربيين ومسلم ان ينظم ذلك
حسنا هذا النوع من التحيز بالنسبه لي مظهر
من مظاهر الجهل كما تعلم فان المفكر
الفلسطيني الكبير ادوارد سعيد دائما ما
يصفه بانه ليس صراع المعرفه بل انه صراع
الجهل انت لا تفهم الاسلام انت تفشل في
فهم العالم العربي
لقد فشلت في فهمه ان اي بلد يمكن ان يتحرك
وينظم بطريقه حديثه ببراعه مع النظام
والانضباط وبالتالي عليك ان تتناول بعض
القضايا المتعلقه بحقوق بعض المجتمعات
وتحترب وتفهم نظام معتقداتنا وثقافتنا لذا
بما انه ليس في المملكه المتحده
فانا نشط تماما في هذه الحمله ضد رهاب
الاسلام فوبيا هذا حتى عندما كنت ادرس في
الولايات المتحده وفي محاضرات لجميع
الجامعات في الولايات المتحده والمؤسسات
قلت لماذا لا يمكن ان نتعلم فقط انا مسلم
وهناك هندوس وبوذيون ومسيحيون موجودون في
ماليزيا لذلك يجب ان يكون لدي نوع من
التفاهم اخذ الكثير من الوقت في تعلم
المسيحيه والبوذيه والهندوسيه لانهم شعبي
لماذا لا يكونوا لديك بعض النزاهه
والاعتدال لمحاوله
الفحمستان حميد دباشي المفكر الايراني
الامريكي يقول هل كتب مقالا لافتا هل
يستطيع غير الاوروبي التفكير انه العقل
الاوروبي مشغول بنفسه وانها هو فقط يعني
مصدر انتاج المعرفه
والاخرين ماده او موضوع للمعرفه
اسلام اسلام
هذا صحيح لانه ينبع من الاسلام فوبيا ولكن
هناك ايضا اعداء للاخر تقرا استشراق
ادوارد سعيد هو الغرب فقط دائما تقرا
صمويل هو صراع الحضارات والفائز سيكون
الغرب الليبرالي وهو امر سخيف
اعني لديك تاريخ عظيم من الحضاره العربيه
الاسلاميه حضرت الصينيه حضاره الهنديه او
امريكا اللاتينيه كيف تتجاهل الاف السنين
من التاريخ لكن علينا التعامل معها هنا في
ماليزيا اعتقد انه في خلال اسبوعين سيكون
لدينا جلسه صغيره للحديث عن الاسلام فوبيا
هنا وهي مهمه جدا لاننا اذا لم نكن حريصين
على التوضيح فسيصاب حتى المسلمون بال
يعتقد الكثير من المسلمين انهم يتعاملون
مع الغرب ومن المثير للاهتمام ان كاس
العالم في قطر اعادت احياء هذا الامر لان
الجميع يرى ان كل شيء على ما يرام
باستثناء اراء الاسلام فوبيا كيف يمكن
لمسلم عربي ان ينظم ذلك بشكل جيد لا لا
يمكننا قبول ذلك لذلك سنجد البعض لا
يسمحون بذلك او بعد ذلك ياتي موضوع
المثليه ويظهر لي انه امر مثير للسخريه
لكن علينا التعامل معها اعتقد ان على
الدول الاسلاميه ايضا بذل المزيد من الجهد
لتثقيف شعوبها وزوارها
شكلت شكلت دره التاج في النهضه ضمن النمور
الاسيويه وخاصه انها بلد مسلم حدث هذا
التراجع الناس الان يعني
تشعر بالحسره لان لا يوجد نموذج اسلامي
نهضوي كبير جدا سنغافوره جارتكم اصغر
بدون موارد انما التقدم لم يتوقف فيها
ماليزيا تعثرت اليوم هل يمكن ان نرى
ماليزيا تعود مره اخرى دوله ناهضه متقدمه
اقتصاديه بشكل كبير جدا
بالضبط يا علي قلت تراجعت قليلا لا لقد
تراجعت كثيرا الحوكمه والاقتصاد والعجز
والديون وعدم وجود استثمارات كبيره جديده
لهذا السبب بالنسبه لبلد ما عليك ان تعترف
بهذا فلدينا قاده يرفضون الاحتراف بذلك
وليس بلدنا بلدا عظيما لقد قمنا بعمل جيد
بشكل ملحوظ انت تواصلوا فعل ذلك انت تحمل
البلد الديون بالنسبه لي انت تقبل نعم
كانت هناك قوه في الماضي هناك الكثير من
الاشياء الجيده ولكن كانت هناك اخطاء
كبيره واخطاء فادحه تسببت في تراجعنا الان
علينا ان ندرك ذلك ان نصحح ذلك
ومن ثم تكون لدينا سياسه واضحه واعتقد ان
نمنحها المزيد من الوقت اعتقد ان هذا
العام في غضون عام او عامين سوف ننتعش هذه
هي قناعتي لا احد يستطيع ان يشكك في حقيقه
اننا حققنا شيئا ما في التسعينيات لكننا
تراجعنا كل المحللين باستثناء السياسيين
في السلطه سيقولون لا ان بلدنا بلد عظيم
ربما يكون اقتصادنا هو الافضل مقارنه ببعض
الدول الافريقيه
وتعليمنا هو رقم واحد صحتنا هي رقم واحد
ليس صحيحا نحن لا ننكر الاشياء الجيده
انتم تنظرون الى البنيه التحتيه الريفيه
في ماليزيا فهي لا تزال افضل من العديد من
البلدان الناميه لكن تم ذلك في التسعينيات
في الثمانينيات لكن لدينا القدره على
القيام بعمل افضل بكثير اذا كان لدينا
قاده يتمتعون بالنزاهه ويمتلكون الفريق
المناسب
ويدفعون بالبلد الى الامام
سعيد جدا بمقابلتك كنت اسال السؤال كيف
ساقابل انور ابراهيم وهو رئيس الوزراء
اليوم بعد كل محاولات تدمير شخصيته وتدمير
سمعته وتدمير مساره السياسي
فلفتني ان اجدك بهذه الحاله من التفاؤل
ومن التواضع الكبير جدا يبدو ان كل
المحاولات لم تجمع لم تنجح في تدميرك
حسنا ما هو الانسان اذا لم يكن لديك هذا
التواضع فهل يمكنك ان تتعلم
هل يمكن ان تتحسن يوما ما
انا اتقبل المشاكل والقضايا لكن عليك ان
تحترف بالحقائق الصارخه وان تتطور
لهذا السبب فان شعارنا الاصلاح ما استطعت
هو محاوله تحسين مستواك بافضل شكل
كان التشويه موجودا منذ عقود لا لسنه
واحده
كان الامر الاكثر تعسفا هو بالاضافه
للاعتداءات الجنسيه كانت انني عميل للغرب
وعميل لوكاله المخابرات المركزيه
وبعد ذلك كنت دميه بيد الصينيين
ودميه بيد الهنود وانا متطرف اسلامي قلت
لهم حسنا لقد بالغتم في تقديري لان
007 هو وكيل لدوله واحده فقط
انا الرجل العظيم بهذا المعنى لذلك انت
تمزح حول ذلك لا تاخذ الامر على محمل الجد
لكنه مهم يمكنني ان اشعر ان الناس عموما
ليس كلهم لكن الكثير من الناس في ماليزيا
يريدون مني ان انجح ليس من اجلي ولكن من
اجل هذا البلد اسمح لي السيد رئيس الوزراء
ان اقول لك يعني تجاوزا القاعده المهنيه
ان هذه واحده من اجمل والطف المقابلات
التي اجريتها في حياتي
انت لطيف للغايه شكرا سيد انور ابراهيم
رئيس الوزراء ماليزيا شكرا جزيلا لك
كل امنياتنا لماليزيا ان تعود ناهضه
ونموذجا استثنائيا كما كانت في السابق وان
تقود ايضا النماذج الاخرى
للبلدان الاسلاميه وغير يعني وغيرها ايضا
للنجاحات شكرا جزيلا لك ان شاء الله امين
اشاهدنا الكرام وصلنا بكم الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه الثانيه من اللقاء من المقابله مع
رئيس الوزراء الماليزي انور ابراهيم
جمله طويلا معه في في ما هو راهم من
الاحداث ما هو ملح الان من قضايا وكذلك ما
هو تاريخي في مسيره الرجل اشكر لكم طيب
المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]